I'm curious about the guitar thing I
know we talked about that briefly okay
but they have been planning the World
Cup for like what eight years all the
stuff was set and then literally four
days ago they go no no alcohol all part
of the plan
you think so I think so the entire time
they know exactly what they're gonna do
the entire time I'm curious what
Budweiser is gonna do budweis is a big
sponsor yeah American sponsor of the
World Cup they've allocated budget to
this right millions of dollars
apparently they're selling Budweiser
zero I mean no alcohol
people are still buying it just for like
the ritual probably of having beer at a
game yeah I mean my dad would do that he
would drink like O'Doul's I think was
yeah back of the day yeah and I guess he
just liked the The Taste and against the
ritual what you're saying but like
I don't know if I'm Budweiser I'm
absolutely [ __ ] furious and I wonder
if this is the last one that happens in
a country that doesn't allow alcohol
consumption because of the sponsorship
because FIFA's got to Bear the weight of
that right not Qatar FIFA's got to
answer those Budweiser calls like
[ __ ] I gave you 10 million
dollars to sponsor this event now I
can't even sell alcohol oh but didn't
Qatar pay mad money to have it there but
to FIFA yeah so now FIFA takes some of
that money and like yo sorry
do you think Budweiser is like okay I'll
take a 10 million dollar payout like
Budweiser these are like billion dollar
Brands like true I I don't know I just
feel like something's got to give with
the sponsorship just the fact that five
million dollars 75 million every four
years that's their normal World Cup
budget so you got to get that money back
yeah that's number one right like we're
in the business selling alcohol not not
alcohol yeah yeah I don't know you tell
me you're Budweiser like break it down
how does that oh you want your money
back dude how many you're gonna to get
drunk you're gonna buy seven eight beers
whatever the [ __ ] it is if you just want
the ritual of drinking a beer at a game
you're buying one beer you were cutting
my consumption alcohol consumption and
by like 80 I think at this point they
just want to kind of probably distance
themselves from whatever fire Fest bad
press it's gonna happen more so for the
lgbtq news that's coming out of Qatar oh
yeah what was that again did you see
they say keep your gay flags and your
gay country they were not having that
[ __ ] no rainbow Flags none of that he's
like respect the customs of our country
now it's really interesting now this is
what I've been this is what I think it's
really interesting they called The Bluff
is that the corporations can't uh take a
moral High Ground on anything right like
apple can't go we're boycotting because
of the way that they treat gays and it's
like well you have slaves making the
phones right but they still all do it
they do it but what happened is uh Qatar
is vocal yeah they'll say it like who do
you think makes your phones like because
that's what we do in the west we just
Outsource anything illegal right it's
like slavery is illegal here so we'll
just buy slaves over there yeah yeah to
make oh [ __ ] right right so it's like
anything we anything that's illegal here
that's what globalization is it's like
well how do we still have slaves
so so they can't exactly say anything
and not be called out for being
hypocrite so they kind of got to be
quiet it's a really interesting Dynamic
you we think in the west that we're on
this moral High Ground about everything
but we're not we just Outsource our [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah we just we just distance
ourselves from immorality exactly put it
in a place we can't see it exactly yeah
and they can call us out on that and
then we can say absolutely nothing so
where we're going into this thing and I
was going oh my God you know not we got
them by the balls but all we gotta do is
say look at this [ __ ] and you're
gonna have all these Americans going
like look at this disgusting regime and
the way that they treat these people and
all they have to do is be like Nike
where do you make your shoes Apple where
do you make your phones don't give us
any [ __ ] about how we have immoral or
unethical practices you're just as
immoral and just as unethical at least
we stand on our [ __ ] and that's kind of
interesting now why why are they Banning
it though that's my question like
obviously there's a religious component
in Qatar homosexuality I'm sure is
illegal right yeah like which also
people keep saying cutter now we're not
saying cutter like that's like the name
of the country yeah yeah it's Qatar we
say guitar my whole life yeah I know and
all of a sudden we just switched it yeah
it's like Ukraine yeah yeah the Ukraine
Ukraine Keith why does it change as soon
as it gets in the media what's happening
well I don't know think about it someone
who speaks Arabic
I live in Qatar have I been pronouncing
it wrong yeah they're gonna sick yeah
probably close because I say Japan I
don't say Nippon like I don't get that
that's not exit inverse an intradome
that's but I'm saying though if we've
been smart yeah yeah
an accident is like a country's name
that is different so Nippon Deutschland
Germany Japan yeah what did why do we
decide what I think we've talked about
this on pod before yeah like we just
yeah but who decide who goes from Nippon
to Japan
easier to say
what about a pond I don't remember the
story of that of white but Products that
come out of Japan are still called like
Nippon made oh wow air Nippon is the
Japanese Airline we're gonna say neeps
yeah neat
God some Wishbone
that's a great Point honestly that's a
great point we name countries based on
how we can be racist towards it yeah
that is fire neeps does not hit it that
does not hit well anyway these Cutters
um they were saying that like I guess
they don't want alcohol being introduced
because then they're afraid of like what
the moral Ripple will be within the
country in the months and years
following the World Cup 100 like oh we
bring in all these Western valleys all
of a sudden all of our people are like
oh these Western values are awesome and
then there's moral erosion amongst the
fun they're gonna have fun
it's like the richest country per capita
so they only have they think 325 000
people so if they're trying to expand
the city based off of like World Cup
success like to become like a Dubai I
think the numbers are it's been 300
billion 45 billion is on their new city
it's called Lucille City 10 billion on
stadiums 30 billion on Metro I'm like it
seems like you want a lot of people
moving over there it's you're not going
to really uh do well if you're going to
ban it fully or maybe they will but
they're not gonna I guess what Dev is
trying to say is like they should be
investing in the tourism aspect yeah
this place like Dubai is but I respect
them for sticking to their guns bro like
I respect yo if being if if alcohol is
illegal
and you don't plan on ever selling
alcohol in the future what is the point
of having the world cup or the Olympics
in your city what is the point tourism
bring people in money funnels and so
that's it right it's tourism it's like
hey this is a cool place you might want
to come back here you might want to tell
your friends about it the world is
watching let's make it look cool if you
have no intention in the future on
selling alcohol which it seems like
Qatar doesn't don't sell a [ __ ] drop
and if you actually think your culture
is dope right if you really believe in
your culture culture will win the
cultural win yeah that's why I respect
boring as [ __ ] but I respect it
but nothing real stand on your shirt
guitar like is your country interesting
enough without alcohol I think no I
think they're probably cultureless and
they're just a bunch of buildings that
are propped up by oil money and it
absolutely is uh [ __ ] hot garbage I
don't know that's awesome I gotta tell
you all about the best wallets in the
business damn right okay you know what's
happening you're walking down the
streets some dude's bumping into you and
he's stealing all your information
you're don't even realize it they don't
got to steal your wallet to steal your
information you know you pay for a
coffee you just tap your phone on the
thing someone could tap your thigh or
your back pocket while you're walking
down the street steal all your [ __ ] not
if you got an extra extra got the RFID
protection it protects you against Boop
steal all your information okay the best
wallet in the business look how cool
they got this nice little leather one
you can even put that little what is
that thing called miles an air or
something
air tag you can even air tag it so you
never have to lose it I'm telling you
this is the best in the business it's
trackable worldwide this is the one
while you will not lose okay you're not
gonna lose the wallet and nobody's gonna
take what's in it from you and it's a
no-brainer because you're getting up to
20 off site-wide when you use the code
flagrant extra.com so check out the
wallets at extra
ekste-r.com and get up to 20 off site
wide with the code flagrant now let's
get back to this exclusive patreon clip
the alcohol by the way is all in their
Club level so their elitists like uh
yeah there's always a thing that bothers
me with all these countries is the
elites still get whatever the [ __ ] in
the arena you've seen it I've seen a
picture already our boys our boys are
currently at the club level inside at
the World Cup
Qatar just lost to Ecuador 2-0 yeah and
um oh yeah there's alcohol in that club
level I think they paid him off that's
what everyone's roasting it's like there
was a apparently I haven't seen the game
but a a bad missed call from uh it was
the first one I was watching it uh
earlier and uh yeah there was a offsides
call on the first goal but then they
scored two more afterwards almost
immediately like you said all this time
spending all this money you could have
been yeah all the players are expats
right on their team yeah yeah it's like
they did that before also with
weightlifting I think remember they
nationalized a bunch of people uh they
nationalized a bunch of Georgians like
from the country Georgia who were like
historic weightlifters they're like oh
you're a Qatari citizen now and I think
they won medals for Qatar yeah they're
trying to buy thousands of years of
trying to buy relevance relevance but
yeah yeah they're trying to buy relevant
if we're getting Olympic gold medals
we're a little bit more relevant if
we're getting World Cup wins we're a
little more with that World Cup is here
or a little bit more relevant I'm just
trying to buy relevant and honestly more
people know Qatar than Kuwait now yeah
think about that they gotta catch it to
Dubai they got a long way to go but how
do they do it if they don't have fun
Western fun no I know well it's kind of
like the way that Saudi Arabia has
bahrained that's close and they all
party over there but
so right now they're I'm seeing a lot of
plays on like it's like a 38 minute
flight to Bahrain no to to Dubai and all
these other places you can come here for
business yeah not fun now if the big
pocket people are still able to have fun
that's the ones that you attract
interesting so now can you make enough
money with that yeah no that's
interesting like yeah I'm curious about
that I think Dubai that's like dark fun
though that's just not like real uh
what's happening
let me let me tell you something that's
really interesting about Dubai and what
they've done brilliantly like
Dubai has done more
with cultural propaganda through that
Real Housewives show than they have
through anything else that they put out
all right what do you mean they have a
real housewives of Dubai I believe it's
under that franchise now they're doing
another show called uh bling something
Dubai bling or something like that
that's going to be on Netflix but
the Dubai show is all I think expats I
don't know if there's any actual
emiratis that are in the show so there's
like a white chick from England there's
a very famous Sudanese model there's
like and they all have husbands and
whatever and they're family Dynamic and
they're doing the same thing that women
do when they get together just [ __ ]
fight with each other whatever but it's
showing the lifestyle it's showing the
luxury it's showing the thing that women
see and they're like oh that'd be kind
of nice my wife is even like I don't
know why I'm kind of like interested in
Dubai a little bit oh [ __ ] and if you
get the wives interested who gotta go
yeah yeah yeah right real quick real
quick so the amount of money that they
paid like let's say for example that
show makes no money but the government
of Dubai or the United Arab Emirates
whatever UAE is paying Bravo whatever
[ __ ] channel to create the show even
as a loss leader it's gonna get me to go
to [ __ ] Dubai with my wife and do all
these things and if life is cool over
there then we might go oh this is a
reasonable place to pop into while I'm
going to a longer flight oh I'm going to
Australia maybe I'll stop over and spend
a few nights in Dubai they're doing the
right thing to create tourism they're
Breaking All the Rules of Islam I mean
there's people [ __ ] there's there's
prostitutes out there there's alcohol
zones which is basically the hotel zones
hotels are international zones they're
like Breaking All the Rules but they're
creating a real tourist destination and
they're doing it with culture instead of
like cool real estate things like
remember they did that palm tree thing
and it's like that looked cool but
nobody wanted to go see it and those
lots were vacant like people didn't even
buy it yeah yeah it's only cool when
you're in a helicopter like you're
creating something that I can only enjoy
from the sky exactly when I'm on it I'm
just on a shitty piece of land yeah but
it is interesting like when you look at
creating hype around your country and
treating it like a tourist attraction
which you [ __ ] need to do once you
run out of that you know those those old
dinosaurs under the ground
how you do it you're gonna you might
have to break some of the laws yeah of
Islam and if Dubai is the first one to
prove that it works does Qatar start to
become a little bit more malleable to
Saudi Arabia the most strict place in
the whole world do they start to go
listen this is our future when we run
out of oil what are we supposed to do
and they're going to have to have
they're gonna have to make a very
difficult choice and that is capitalism
or a slum it is so hard to compete with
Western culture we've had this talk
before but the idea that you just do
what makes you happy is the most
intoxicating idea in human history yeah
do what makes you happy let's drink
let's have sex let's do all the stuff
that's completely anti-islam yes it
makes me happy God might make me feel
fulfilled and truly happy but this makes
me feel good and yeah momentary
immediate happiness I don't know the
difference you know how old you got to
get for you know the difference in those
two yeah yeah most people don't they die
not knowing so that's really like the
only hope America has against China so
so here's my question you know how like
Russia has uh gotten its citizens
comfortable with
um despair discomfort yeah and
discomfort like I mean it sounds kind of
like Consulting but like the people
there like I think like some crazy
percentage somebody told us this like 40
of Russians don't have like running
toilets or something like that like some
crazy number now granted there are a lot
of places outside of [ __ ] Moscow and
uh St Petersburg that you know a little
way more Rural right that being said the
people that are a little bit more
comfortable with discomfort
the Middle East is the opposite
right these oil countries have become
incredibly comfortable with luxury yet
and if that oil dries up
are you going to make the sacrifices
necessary the sacrifices to Islam
necessary to maintain
that luxury
because please believe if you don't have
that oil propping it up you're going to
need tourism and people are not going to
fly all the way out there to smoke
hookah
yeah you're gonna need to sell some
alcohol you're gonna need to sell some
[ __ ] Egypt is so grateful for their
pyramids they're like thank God they
have a Taurus we have something for
people to come look at white people
specifically you know what I mean like
like it's so funny Muslims they don't
need to see no [ __ ] pyramids they
don't see the block yeah they won't spin
the block literally they won't spin the
block Mecca let's go and there's a few
other like very historic sites right
there's Alexa and uh Jerusalem and
there's
I think there's a there's a top three
I'm [ __ ] it up but like
there are these things that are like so
important to you because of like what
what the religion means right yeah
but you won't want Asians like you go to
Paris you take your girl to Paris right
yeah that's me poem
right it's like in the Medina yeah but
it's like a thing Paris syndrome is like
when like uh like Asian or like Japanese
Chinese tourists like go to Paris and
then they're like faint like have panic
attacks because it's not what they
thought it was like on TV or whatever
yeah yeah the disappointment the sheer
disappointment they built up their one
trip their whole life to see this most
beautiful place but like the whole world
has gone to Paris and the French have
been doing this for years I think it was
Louis the the Sun King who is he losing
16 maybe it was 16th and like yeah they
basically
they're like the Kardashians they're
like flexed [ __ ] that they didn't even
have they were broke you know what I
mean but they made it look like they had
everything and people from around the
world were coming to go like pay 500 000
or whatever to watch the guy take a [ __ ]
like it was crazy don't disrespect the
Kardashians like that yeah
23 of uh Russia still doesn't have 23
sewage systems
Louis XIV the 14th but I don't know
isn't that kind of interesting like
you're gonna have a real conundrum right
you've gotten your you've gotten your
people used to a lifestyle that you're
not going to be able to maintain when
that oil shuts off yeah I wonder if
they're trying to just attract like
other Muslims like is there a play where
they're like Okay We're Not Gonna
compromise on our values the way like
Dubai has but we are going to create the
coolest City that all the Muslims wanted
and I see being possible because that's
really well located yeah I saw that map
of all the direct flights from Kuwait
from this so you can capture huge
Muslims let's get all the rich yemenis
Let's get all the rich and they don't
want to live in Dubai because it's just
Taurus and debauchery so what if we can
create
you're underestimating how many Muslims
there are in the world it's like an
Islamic you just need to appeal to them
yo this is so interesting right so uh
how many Muslims total uh
um
no but that's a great point
and then you kind of make Dubai look
like this like Western washed white wash
yeah
oh it's uh the Middle East for white
people and then because I bet you all
the real like Muslims probably see this
and they're like oh this is awesome
because they're not compromising on
their values they're [ __ ] with the
religion and it's also kind of a middle
finger to like the West yes and it's
like most Muslim the country with the
most Muslims Indonesia you can attract
so many people yeah you can get all the
malays you get pakistanis not people
that would adhere to the rules that want
to see something now the question that's
different about that is
are those Muslims around the world
wealthy enough
to support a tourist economy in a very
expensive city like Doha Doha is in
Guitar yeah like Doha like you know what
I mean like the reason why people want
to attract the West is because we have
money like yeah yeah the other thing I
don't know if Indonesians I don't know
what the Indonesian economy is right
it's a tour City or it's a it's a city
of universities and research and you're
spending that money on that I do really
like that idea real quick I do really
like this idea like let's just Target
Muslims yeah they're making Muslim
wakanda
it's like we're just gonna get all the
like we don't even need all the Muslims
like because not all of them can come
over but like if they can go on a Hajj
like on the way they can pop pop in and
like make it what is it Disneyland for
Muslims yeah right like what is
everything is catered to them the way
that they're going to the movies the way
they're going to dine the way that
they're every aspect of the culture is
the most refined amazing quality food
amazing Quality Music it's Vegas but
without all the debauchery without all
the sin that you're trying to avoid
anyway it's like it's really convenient
if you're a die-hard Believer is there a
place like this already like do they go
to Riyadh do they go to but but Saudi
Arabia ain't got [ __ ] that's the thing
like yeah they don't have fun I don't
know what Riyadh is like like is there a
city like is there a metropolis like a
Muslim Metropolis like Dubai would have
to be it well whatever
fake like they're westernized because I
could still keep it contained in certain
areas you still walk around the street
the women still have to cover up and
right stuff so it's like here's what I'm
also wondering though you convince
yourself that the country you can't
convince even though you know on some
level they're wavering and that's what's
gonna happen in Guitar same [ __ ] oh
you're saying it's only a matter of time
because even this is a point I was gonna
bring up even in the theocracies like I
have some friends who live in Pakistan
and they were we're hanging out and they
drank and I was like oh and they were
like yeah actually most people in
Pakistan drink you don't think that but
that same thing probably happens it's
probably happening in Qatar right now
people are drinking but on what Mark was
saying a nice [ __ ] you to the West is
now you don't get to bring your little
[ __ ] over here we're gonna drink but
when you fly over here you gotta be us
because we all we got all weekend
every time we go out there I think
that's part of it yeah
it's a really cool play and I think it's
a really smart play
and
I'm just curious how many Muslims are
gonna leave their country to go to
like the bougie Muslim version of it
since a lot of those countries in the
Middle East their oil countries are
already incredibly wealthy like they
have to find something to make it
interesting to make it yeah I don't know
what it thought though it's you have a
country of three million people and
those three million people see Dubai and
they see people moving to London that's
like a last-ditch effort to make sure
that they hold on to their young that
are in Qatar they want to be in a cool
City otherwise they're gonna leave oh
okay what about this you do exactly what
they're doing you have the World Cup you
have F1 you have every main major event
that you possibly could have right so
you have whatever band is the biggest
band you have constant events you event
ties the country that's your
entertainment outside of that your
country's not gonna be that different
from Kuwait or any of these other
incredibly wealthy oil countries but
they do have the things so you make sure
those relationships allow you to have
those things whoever the biggest Muslim
comedian is in the world he got to be
performing there yeah and then it
becomes the a destination for anything
that is uh culturally I don't know has
like cultural what is it um not
homogeneous Maybe
one of my what is the word I'm working
for
well it doesn't matter so uh Synergy
right so uh yeah then it's Vegas it's
Muslim Vegas yeah yeah right like that's
smart but you have to eventize it just
having nice hotels it's like they got
that in every other way Vegas is Vegas's
biggest thing was what happens in Vegas
stays in Vegas that's what honestly
apparently that like it was a massive
tourism push in Vegas after that I
campaign yeah
they don't have that are people excited
about the World Cup this is your time to
shine I think there's like in my opinion
at least at least the way I feel is like
there is like a stain on it a little bit
wow like the World Cup what makes it so
fun is like it's pure it happens in the
summertime so everyone's feeling good
and like people are out and partying
isn't it in the summer because it's in
the Middle East it's hot too hot crazy
hot that's the controversy and it's
during champions league and any true
soccer football fan is gonna pick
Champions League over the world cup
anytime and they're like stopping the
season in the middle of it to do the
World Cup
us at winning a champions league and
then imagine like a player gets injured
at the cup now happens that already
happened yeah Benzema messed up his
thigh like I think that was in training
though I don't think it was with uh with
the club but yeah it's just a shame like
it feels like like the spirit is taken
away the whole point of it is it feels
like the New York City marathon but like
around the world you know what I mean
where it's like everyone's just like
cheering and there's like yeah like
pride and everyone comes together and
there's like Global Harmony and then
it's like tainted with like money and
Corruption and like slaves dying
building the stadium at least not in the
World Cup by the way yeah Italians are
roasting this [ __ ] out of this world
there's something really interesting
about like when the World Cup happens
though like just being at a bar like I
was at uh we were I was at Jax or
whatever earlier today and I'm sitting
next to an Irish guy who is watching the
game on his phone and an Ecuadorian
bartender is watching as well right and
a gay like super flaming gay Ecuadorian
bartender there's something about soccer
that cuts through all that [ __ ] like you
were still a soccer fan like when it's
with your country so he's watching the
game with the Irish guy and me and I'm
the most Outsider and like all of us
really are congealed into this like one
moment locked into this game it's
beautiful yeah yeah and it's awesome in
New York specifically especially in the
states it doesn't really hit the same
unless you're in a big city because you
have all the cultures yeah but when
you're in a big city it's like I
remember World Cup uh 2018 just like
walking down the street and it's just
like every bar is playing it and like
everyone's just like wearing it just I
don't know for me at least because I'm
noticing It Like It Felt Like A vibe
that's a cool Vlog is you you find the
day that has the most games what are
their total like uh four games a day or
something like that okay so three games
a day no two games today I think oh
maybe just two games a day even in this
beginning stages yeah you're right in in
group stage and then thank you
this is also the most crunch World Cup
they've ever had so it's the most games
in the fewest days oh why I don't know
why they did I'm assuming because they
have to capitulate with the Champions
League yeah so like we have to shrink
down the days they can't just stop the
season for the whole time exactly
whereas like in the summer time you have
two and a half you have three months
basically okay so you do four games
that's eight teams it'd be kind of cool
to go to a bar like for the first half
you're at the Ecuador bar second half
you're at the whatever Qatar bar that
wouldn't be one but uh you'd be
surprised though there are there's
probably restaurants there's probably
Qatari restaurants that are playing the
games that are they packed wouldn't that
be dope
that's what I love about New York
especially like there is a multiple bars
for every team and for every country
like I saw France playing the final in
2018 and it was just out of French like
bar restaurant thing and it was just
packed only French people it was crazy
yeah it's so fun yeah it's awesome so
fun even less is like us world cup and a
bar where everybody's rooting for the US
is so fun yeah we did that yeah yeah
remember when we were playing against I
think we went to something on St Marks
yeah I remember that we're playing
against Ghana yeah and you know that was
the other thing about it I know it
sounds like we're geeking out over
soccer and like people listening right
now like finally you [ __ ] get it it's
not soccer specifically but I do
appreciate that the collective care of a
thing like it's why a show is great like
House of dragons or Game of Thrones it's
like Breaking Bad like everybody getting
excited about the same thing is awesome
it's so rare now with the internet that
we get to do that but um
I never feel uncomfortable walking into
any bar to watch a soccer match and I
don't know if that's something specific
to soccer hmm like if I walked into like
a Chiefs bar a Kansas City Chiefs bar in
New York to watch a game I would feel a
little uncomfortable yeah I'm not a
Kansas City Chiefs fan like oh yeah and
if they find out you're not a Chiefs fan
it's a whole somebody just making
comments
or something like I think it's like an
American thing I'll be honest yeah
because like yeah you walk into like a
soccer bar in America and you're like oh
no one here really gives a [ __ ] about
anything okay that's it though okay I
think if you're like in Liverpool and
you walk into like a Liverpool board
you're like oh there's a Vibe like yeah
I would feel a little bit more like a
voyeur yeah but if my team is playing
yeah like if America is playing yeah I
can walk into any bar and we're all on
the same page and everybody is rooting
for the same thing it is yeah it's
really cool that's the cool thing with
sporting like national teams is that you
already are opted into supporting the
team yeah like just by virtue of being
American you're like I have a choice
yeah like this is my team I guess I was
made here yeah it's like when you go to
like a dinner show and they just see you
in like the green section and you're
like I'm a fan of the green guy yeah you
know what I mean like that's what it is
but like on a global level yeah so but I
think like the corruption thing and all
the money that's [ __ ] it up it's
taken away from it like people are like
sure was even telling me that they were
apparently like eight to ten Ecuadorian
players that were being bribed by the
Qatari government allegedly
to throw the game to lose one nil
and there's like a big controversy where
it's like did they actually do it
obviously they won two nothing so like
that wasn't a case but like people were
like oh they're gonna try to throw games
Qatar is the first team to host a World
Cup to lose an opening match
so and they gave them what the worst
team is Ecuador have actually a good
team I mean they're decent like
Ecuador's pretty good I mean how much do
you have to pay me there's a number
right are you kidding me Ecuador
Jesus Christ you don't think Ecuador's
willing I mean what are they they're
probably like the second poorest country
in
central slash South America I don't know
I mean most of those guys probably have
professional contractors like at least
you know I think they're probably all on
professionals I give a billion dollars
to the government that ain't nothing you
don't think that they're throwing a game
for two million dollars I guarantee I
could bribe a soccer player an
Ecuadorian soccer Blair I could buy it
for two million 100 I don't know it's
100 I don't know look I got a guarantee
but yeah people are saying it's like
yeah they're [ __ ] buying games and
[ __ ] so I don't know it kind of
tarnishes it but I think people are
still watch it and still love it because
it's yeah they get to see hopefully
Messi and Ronaldo play everyone's
[ __ ] watching it yeah I heard uh they
think Messi got a good chance this year
Argentina's got a really strong team
this is his last World Cup so a lot of
people are thinking this might be it
might finally happen
is there a chance of Argentina and
Portugal playing in the finals the way
that the brackets are lined up think so
yes right there whoa oh really oh no
because I did a bracket
[Laughter]
that would be absolutely [ __ ] Wild
also people kept texting me that uh
they're like yo y'all made it and I was
like what's up and they sent me the
video where Messi is doing a turn your
phone oh [ __ ] I was like yeah that's it
I mean if Messi's turned the phone
that's crazy we we did it we changed
culture guys that's crazy okay I'm a
team Ronaldo did you see how Budweiser
responded last thing what did I say they
tweeted out a picture of a massive
Warehouse full of the like the Branded
World Cup Beer it's a massive warehouse
and they said new day new tweet winning
country gets all of the buds who's gonna
get them so apparently they're going to
like they haven't discussed the details
on it but they're like in a statement
they were like yeah we want to give all
of these buds away to the winning like
the winning country and put them in
their Stadium somehow they haven't
figured out like the details but I think
that's what they're gonna do and how
they stay relevant with this whole like
controversy that's smart yeah that's
pretty cool yeah I don't know if that is
the answer but that's a good PR approve
you've got to use the energy like that
PR team right now got to be cooking on
something yeah
like I mean do you have just like can
you fly a plane with
no but they've definitely knew about
this for a while because the fact that
there's no lawsuits they already have
the Bud Light zero ready to go like
they've they've known for a while yeah I
think so oh okay it would be instant
lawsuit the amount had Bud Light zero
created
zero the amount of Bud Light zero that
they have at the games
yeah if they have enough Bud Light zero
for every person that's in the stance
they knew that they weren't selling a
single bit alcohol
the fact that they haven't run out
already
no who gets more like zero fast that's
what I'm saying come on
but again if you're buying a
non-alcoholic beer you're having one
you're not I don't know yo what if all
these soccer fans finally realize it's
boring
they're like yeah but that's just there
yeah but I'm not around the rest of the
world though yeah because they're not
but like all like the British people
that went there like watching games
sober and they're like but where's the
scoring man
they're just gonna kick it around a bit
the best part of it is
that's not stupid [ __ ] you do you know
they realize there's just a shitty sport
after all they were just absolutely
blitzed it that's great yeah this is
what the world needed basketball just
takes over